thanks for the introduction thanks for
the invitation so as you can guess from
my affiliation i belong to the applied
world
and
as you can also guess from the
cycle of the talk i would like
to think about some
in my opinion interesting
facts about convex relaxation of
graph isomorphism
problems
i would like to start with an example
and there are actually
plenty of such examples in
for example in computer vision
let's say i have two
two objects two
two objects that i can endure with some
structure and i would like to
find
the best structure preserving map
between such objects and just to be
concrete
let's say
i equip
these many folds with a distance for
example i have
a manifold x with a distance dx and
another manifold
while with the distance d1 i would like
to find
a mapping between
these two spaces that
minimizes
this distortion of the magic
actually it appears to be a very hard
problem and there are many works
including my my own works and
not only on how to find such maps but
also how to represent them because in
practice these shapes
can contain hundreds of thousands and
maybe millions of points
it is a very tough computational problem
to find find these maps
and
very it is very disappointing that
there are many words
to attack these problems that work
exceptionally well but there are no
theoretical guarantees usually they all
boil down to
some non-context optimization problems
so the only guarantee that you can get
is that you converge to a local minimum
but you don't really get
the best
distance preserving touch some reason
why the colors are reversed
one has a blue left hand and the other
has a right well if you if you are
matching distances for example there is
no way you can resolve this symmetry so
i will i will speak about symmetries in
particular so significance are one of
the
of the problem
uh that
plugs the
the the easy solution
yes
okay so so and basically
basically it is
very it is very appealing uh to model
this problem with graphs so i can i can
think of these manifolds and of course
there are many other examples of
uh of the problems where the need to
find such structure preserving uh
correspondence correspondence is the
right for example in
neuroscience people try to match
uh brain networks
they can be represented by by graphs so
basically i'm interested in
given two graphs finding
an isomorphism or some approximation of
the isomorphism between the graphs
so i
i already need to apologize for the
terminology i will use the terminology
that is very
frequently used or i should say abused
in the applied community usually the
applied community
speaks about graph matching problems but
they refer vaguely to graph isomorphism
problems of different kinds so i will
distinguish between
uh the graph isomorphism problem which
asks whether there exists
an isomorphism between between two
graphs and i will be talking about
weighted undirected graphs that i will
be representing using the adjacency
matrices and b
of course these are these are two
symmetric matrices
and graph exact exact graph matching
problem will be actually to find
such
an isomorphism versus inexact graph
matching where the graphs might not be
exactly
isomorphic but then i will be
interested in finding some uh minimum
distortion isomorphism in some sense
okay
so
so if i formulate this as an
optimization problem basically i can
think of my isomorphism if i assume that
the graphs have the same number of
vertices
myosomorphism can be represented as
permutation matrices so i will be
minimizing some distortion
between a and
the adjacency matrix b multiplied by the
permutation from the left and from the
right so this permutes the vertices of
the graph
i will be minimizing this over the space
of
permutation matrices
and actually this is a funny problem
because it is known to be np it is not
known to bnp complete but there is also
no
known polynomial time algorithm for
solving it so it looks like it is a hard
problem but
probably there are some cases where
this problem actually becomes trivial
i will mention just a few
and
it appears at least in the in the
in the applied community it appears that
among the set of many heuristics that
have been proposed for solving such
problems
uh convex relaxations work extremely
well
so i will just do some algebraic
manipulations to this problem so first
of all i will use here the l2 norm
and
if you go back to the
example of
pairwise distance preservation actually
this l2 norm has a lot of geometric
meanings basically i'm trying to
minimize some
uh some uh
l2 energy of the discrepancies between
the
between the
of the pairwise distances
between
the points on my two
shapes well because the l2 norm is
invariant to orthogonal transformation
then permutation matrix is orthogonal i
can
transform the problem into this form
and then so and so and then i can
replace my space of permutation matrices
which is a very ugly space to do
optimization on i can actually replace
it by its convex hull but it's called
the polito this is
the space of doubly stochastic matrices
and this objective is convex the set uh
the feasible side is also a convex so i
get a quadratic program
so
yes
do people also study the case in which e
and b don't have the same number of
verbs this is yes yes of course
for example doing partial matching but i
i will i will keep it simple of course
it is a much more interesting case to
discuss so there if you have partial
matching then you can show that it's p
it is np complete
but i will i will keep
i will stick to the to the
full matching case where basically i
have the same number of vertices and i'm
interesting am i interested in finding
the uh the bijection
between the two graphs
so this is the typical convex relaxation
that is
practiced and it worked it works really
well it can actually with some fix it
can scale to
sufficiently large graphs
but
in general the solution of this problem
of course is not a permutation
you will get some doubly stochastic
matrix which
nobody guarantees it will be a
permutation so you need to project it
back to quantize it back onto the space
of
permutations and this can be done by for
example by
finding the maximum inner product
between
the solution of the conductor relaxation
and a permutation matrix and
it appears to be what is called
the linear assignment problem
there is a family of algorithms usually
known as hungarian algorithm
that can solve these in polynomial time
and actually you can think about a much
simpler
projection here that i will will mention
in in this video
so when there are actually there are
way better ways of doing this projection
that
also work in practice but i will again
stick to this very
simple formulation
okay
so the general recipe that i'm going to
follow i will solve this convex
relaxation of the
problem i will refer to this problem as
graph matching and again apologies for
the abuse of terminology and then i will
do the projection
okay
and of course the question i would like
to ask what is the relation between
this pi hat which is the result of the
projection and pi star which is my
uh my isomorphism that i'm trying to
find
so well obviously pi star is a solution
of the conex relaxation it is actually a
global global minimum because it will
give me
it will give me zero here
it is also doubly stochastic matrix
but of course the converse is not true i
might get some
some doubly stochastic stochastic matrix
here by p star
that will fall into some wrong voronoi
cell in my space of
permutations
that will give me some non-zero
distortion
and here i must must admit uh i must
express my frustration so i asked many
people from or some people from
uh that are supposed to be experts in in
graph theory probably i asked the wrong
people
uh
and they they were not able to tell me
much about
uh what can i guarantee
what relations can be guaranteed between
these
the solution of the relaxation and the
true isomorphism of course there are
some graphs
for which
trivial things can be said for example
if i have a bipartite graph or a tree
there are trivial algorithms that can
give me the exact isomorphisms but in
general it looks like
not so much is known about the relation
between between these two problems
okay
so what i will try to show you
is some i would say elementary analysis
of this of this problem so maybe i will
be saying trivial things
but at least i hope
to convince you that it leads to some
interesting observations okay and
of course uh please be welcome to
uh challenge anything i'm saying yes
so um what about if you have a kelly
graph because there is a lot of
literature also on group bytes
well
again i will be i will be happy to hear
more about about specific structures of
graphs but
i started with the problem where i have
a graph that
sort of represents this discrete matrix
space or something that for example is
sampled from a low dimensional manifold
maybe with
smoothness properties or bounds on
dimension and curvature so
i don't think there are any results that
make use of such properties
and i would be of course very happy to
to see how the these properties can be
used of course there are there are many
classes of graphs where a lot can be
said but
for general graphs it is not
solved to be unique no so i will
basically all the problems will arise
from cases where the isomorphism is not
unique
okay so
so first of all the relaxation space
itself uh
so the relaxation space itself that uh
people are using is the convex hull of
permutation matrices this is the
tightest convex realization that you can
think about but i will be using a
different relaxation so i would like to
drop the non-negativity constraints and
i would like to drop one of the
uh
one of the
either row or column sums constraints so
instead of talking about doubly
stochastic matrix matrices i will be
talking about what i probably should
call pseudostochastic matrices so they
have
the rows sum to one
but there are no non-negativity
constraints so it's in a fine space it's
a much coarser relaxation of the
original problem
so there are no
non-over there are no overlapping
constraints and there are no
non-negativity constraints and from
practical perspective this can help a
lot to solve these optimization problems
and maybe to scale to larger ends
so i will be considering this this
relaxation and uh
i will define a particular class of
graphs where this relaxation i will show
it will give exact the exact isomorphism
so
i will be giving a spectral
characteristic and by spectral i'm
referring not to the spectrum of the
laplacian of the graph but the spectrum
of the
of the adjacency matrix and actually it
would be interesting to find
correspondences between these results to
the spectrum of the oppression because
obviously their passion is well more
more researched and also
it can be easier easier
the connection to the underlying smooth
structure for example smooth manifold
is probably much easier to obtain
so i will call a graph friendly if
its
adjacency matrix has a simple spectrum
and another funny condition is that no
eigenvectors
are orthogonal to a constant
vector of ones
so so basically sort of there are
so you can think of the projection of
the eigenvectors on one is sort of the
dc
speaking in signal processing terms
so there are no
uh eigenvectors that have zero dc
component
okay
of course of course this excludes the
regular graphs so i would i will say
something about how to get rid of this
condition but
this excludes the regular graph exactly
so first of all this
friendliness property actually has a
almost trivial connection to
to symmetry it is very easy to show that
friendly graphs are asymmetric or
meaning that they have trivial
automorphism group
and actually it's very it's very easy so
if i assume that my
adjacency matrix admits this
unitary eigen decomposition
and let's say pi is some non-trivial
symmetry of
of this graph so pi a equals 8 pi
well
then uh
then basically for for every i a u i
equals lambda i ui these these are
eigenvectors and corresponding
eigenvalues i can multiply both sides by
pi and i get this
but because pi a equals a pi i get this
and this means that
pi ui is an eigenvector of a
corresponding to the same eigenvalue as
ui
now
because a was assumed to have simple
spectrum this means that pi ui is equal
either to plus or minus ui because i'm
assuming of course that the vector
vectors are units
so they must be linearly dependent
but we also assumed that
pi was
a non-trivial symmetry this means that
there will be some eigenvector for which
pi ui equals to minus
ui
and because
because of that
1 times pi ui will be equal to minus 1
the inner product with ui
but pi is also permutation so of course
it has
a
unique
sum of of the columns
so from these two results i i'm getting
that
the inner product of ui with vector of
ones equals to zero which of course
contradicts the assumption that this
graph was friendly so basically uh
basically this property is actually
giving me the fact that that the
friendly graphs are asymmetric and of
course the the converse is not true you
can think of of a
regular graph that is asymmetric for
example the fruit graph or
there are many graphs that you can
construct with probably
about something like starting from 10
vertices and more
but
i
probably i shouldn't be
getting into this point but i can argue
that such graphs are not so frequent and
i i would like to
to keep off any arguments regarding some
natural distributions of of graphs but i
will i will touch this point and if if i
forget please remind me
so so i will show three results that are
basically versions of
this result but the main result is
very simple and i will show you an
elementary argument
to prove it basically
saying that if we have
a and b two friendly isomorphic graphs
then the convex relaxation will give the
exact
unique isomorphism we know that it's
unique because friendly graphs are
asymmetric
and of course because
i'm already getting the exact isomer
freezing from the convex relaxation it
will survive projection in exactly the
same form so basically after projection
it will still be the same as
and here actually well we need to we
need to check two assumptions so
checking whether the graphs are
isomorphic is hard obviously this
it is the hard problem that we're trying
to solve by
resorting to the relaxation but checking
friendliness is easy it's a spectral
property so what i will do in practice i
will check friendliness and then solve
the relaxation if as a result i get zero
distortion this result
guarantees me that what i got
is
is a unique isomorphism
otherwise if i got non-zero distortion
this result guarantees me that the
graphs are not isomorphic
okay
any any questions so far
so let me show you a very
elementary
argument
to prove this uh to prove this statement
so i will assume two graphs a and b
with
some isomorphism pi star relating
between them and these graphs are
friendly so pi star is unique
so we are interested in solving this
convex quadratic program which is
over relaxed it is a bigger relaxation
that is typically used in practice
and of course i know that
pi star is its global minimizer if i
substitute it here it will get zero
what i would like to show that this
minimizer is unique
so what i will do first i will
reparameterize this problem by
first of all substituting instead of a i
will substitute this form and then
multiply everything by pi star transpose
again the l2 norm is invariant to
orthogonal transformation so i will get
this
i will call this matrix
p pi star transpose i will call it q
it's also www
stochastic matrix and in particular it
will also admit
this space of constraints so i can
easily do these three parameterization
and because of the particular form of
the constraints
here on the right hand side i have i
have the same vector of months
i can reorder these constraints in any
order in particular i can also put p by
star transpose here
so i'm getting this problem i will write
it in terms of this new matrix q
and
the global minimizer of this problem now
is q equals identity
this is sort of assuming some canonical
numbering of the vertices of both graphs
and again i need to show that this
minimizer is unique
okay
so
of course i can formulate first order
optimality conditions for this
optimization problem so the lagrangian
the the
the derivative of the organization with
respect to q has to be zero
with some set of lagrange multipliers
alpha and after simple calculus you will
be getting this expression
now i will substitute
this eigen decomposition for b
okay
and then
multiply
both sides by u your transpose you will
be getting this
so it will be again
using a different
set of uh variables so i will be now
expressing my unknown in the eigen basis
of the adjacent symmetric so i will call
this matrix f
okay
and gamma will be the set of lagrange
multipliers in the eigen basis of the
adjacency and v will be the projection
of
one of a vector of ones
on
on u
okay
and remember because we assumed that
this that our graphs are friendly no
entry here is zero
okay
so basically i need to solve this system
with respect to f and gamma
and obviously what i'm going to show
that this system is full rank
so i can write it in coordinates you see
it's a complete square here so i can
write it in coordinates like this it
will be f
i j multiplied by the square differences
between lambda lambda j plus v j gamma
so if in particular i
look at the diagonal of this system
i'm getting v i gamma i equals 0 and i
know that no vi
no vi is zero so this means that gamma
is zero i can eliminate
this second term from the from the
system and i'm getting this
okay
now because of friendliness i know that
for any i this things from j lambda is
also distinct from the j
so this means that f is diagonal
okay and because i also know that q
has all rows summing to one
i can write this in terms of f like this
okay so i'm getting f v equals v
now because now v equals zero the only
diagonal matrix that will satisfy this
is the identity matrix obviously
of course because f is i
then q is also i
okay
so this basically shows that i have a
unique minimizer but the system is full
rank
question so far
well
at this point you can argue that this is
completely uninteresting because if i
have matrices with simple spectrum i can
simply compare the two
eigenbases of the two graphs and get the
exact permutation actually i will get
the permutation up to a sine
but i can then just cancel the signs and
this will give me the permutation but i
will try to convince you that
this way of looking at the problem will
still give some results that probably
much more they are more difficult to
obtain if you
just try to compare the the eigenvectors
okay so so one such result would be
let's see what
if this result is stable let's do a
perturbation to our graph so instead of
friendliness i will assume a slightly
stronger property
i will assume that the spectrum is
separated by some delta
and
that
that the projection of the constant
vector on my eigenvectors is bigger than
some epsilon okay so it will be a
strongly friendly graph
and
and then basically i can show that
for two graphs a and b
that satisfy this stronger property
that they are that they are
approximately isomorphic with a constant
row and by approximately isomorphic i
mean that there is there exists an
isomorphism that
uh
has distortion smaller than raw
so then if
this row is smaller than some constant
that depends on delta and epsilon
then the distance between
the solution of the convex
relaxation and
the true isomorphism will be bounded in
the
in the infinity norm by one half
okay and obviously if it is bounded by
one half
then it means that you can even naively
quantize this result by simply taking
all the entries that are smaller than
one one half to zero and bigger than one
half to one
so this projection will give you
obviously
the exact isomorphism again
and the proof is very it's very simple
basically we have a full rank system and
you you put these constraints to the
guarantee that a sufficiently small
perturbation will keep it full rank and
then you use uh
linear regular perturbation
theory
to actually tell how the solution is
going to change and the the expression
here is ugly
and uh depends unfortunately on the size
of the graph
but uh
it at least it shows that the the
problem is stable and actually it will
be very interesting to
to do some more delicate analysis here
for example if you can tell something
about the spectral properties of your
perturbation like something that
only affects higher frequencies of your
uh of
of your graph and for example doesn't
affect the core structure maybe you can
put some better bounds here
so of course it is very it is very
important in in practice
well and here again
i will not
check
this property i will just
verify that this strong friendliness
property is satisfied and then i will
solve the relaxation if the result is
smaller than the bound then i have a
theoretical guarantee that
my
uh that my solution is
is the exact isomer phase or not exactly
is the approximate isomorphism that is
the global minimum otherwise
uh this result guarantees me that the
graphs
are not
uh
raw isomorphic
okay the same story we had with
with the uh with the case of the exact
isomorphism
any questions so far
do you know what rho actually is well
there is basically this ugly expression
i can show it too explicitly but i don't
think
well it will depend on epsilon and delta
some powers of epsilon delta and some
power of n
so i i don't remember remember it
exactly but
at least i don't find too much insight
in this specific expression
okay any other questions
okay so some experimental validation of
this result so maybe maybe this sort of
plots will be
uh
will be very intuitive to
to people who work on
matrix completion or compressed sensing
or these sort of problems basically they
call it in that community phase
transition plots basically
uh i randomized
strongly friendly graphs and then added
different
levels of noise to each of these graphs
so basically the noise just to
plot everything on the same axis
i'm
normalizing the noise by
this specific bound so for every graph
of course it will be a different
different constant so the noise is
normalized to this bound so it means
that when i'm adding noise of one
normalized noise of one
the bound with the bound is supposed to
hold and then
the bound is there is no more
theoretical guarantee well actually i
was expecting to to get that because
because of this very crude analysis i
was expecting to get something that is
very far from being tied but actually
here it appears that there are some
graphs that start violating this bound
already for a very small amount of noise
and then of course as you increase the
amount of noise then with
then uh
there is higher and higher probability
of not being able to recover the
the isomorphism and actually maybe so
maybe i am cheating a little bit here
because it might happen that the noise
i'm i'm
adding will actually create me an
isomorphism that is better than the
ground truth that that i assumed and i
of course have no way of checking it
because it would be it would require
solving the exact uh or enumerating all
the all the local meaning of of of this
objective function which is the model
you know
just just random gaussian noise with the
id interesting
i'm just adding the noise to the
adjustments of course it has to be
symmetric and zero diagonal
so
of course in in practice when i think of
my graph as a metric space for example
coming from a smooth manifold
uh there are some constraints on the
noise because if the points still reside
on the manifold there are many
dependencies between between between the
entries but this is a very simplistic
noise model
any other questions
yes what is the side of the graph here
well here here i randomized graphs from
basically a few n equals let's say from
five to about 50 or something like that
50 is not well 50 is not a big graph but
otherwise it takes too much time because
there are many many experiments averaged
here
but i guess it is it is
large enough to for some interesting
phenomena to start happening already
okay so
so let's see what happens when we
violate these friendliness assumptions
so
i will assume now that my adjacency
matrix doesn't have
simple spectrum
so we have
the first eigen space with some
multiplicity n plus one then followed by
second eigen space with multiplicity of
n plus two and sorry m two plus plus one
and so on so this this m 1 m 2 and
up to m d
will be counting
how non-simple
is each of the eigen spaces so if m i
equals 0 it means that i have a simple
eigen space
and i will sum them into some
constant m
so it measures how non-simple is my
graph
okay
so then of course because once i have
no simple eigen spaces there is no
unique way of defining my eigenvectors
so
then what shall i do with this demand of
not being orthogonal to one
it might happen for example if this is
my eigen space and this is the vector of
ones it might happen that i will choose
one of the eigenvectors that will be
orthogonal to
this by chance right so i will assume by
convention that
i will always avoid
such such situations unless of course
the entire eigen space
is orthogonal to the vector of one then
i have no choice then all my
eigenvectors will be orthogonal to one
so then it allows to distinguish between
two two situations one situation is
where the entire eigen space is
orthogonal to one i will call it hostile
well it will create
some
more degeneracy in my system of
equations otherwise it will be
non-hostile
okay and i will count by
this constant k
the number of hostile eigen spaces
okay
so then i can
assign this m plus k as some sort of
unfriendliness degree of my graph and of
course if it's zero my graph is friendly
as
in the previous in the previous
discussion
okay
so then it's very easy to show that
symmetric graphs meaning that graphs
that have non-trivial automorphisms
with l non-trivial and such non-trivial
automorphism will have this
unfriendliness degree
at least of size l and the argument is
very simple
event similar to what we showed in the
asymmetric case
so then we showed that for any
non-trivial symmetry
there exists some
eigen eigenvector ui such that pi ui
distinct from ui
will be an eigenvector of the adjacency
matrix corresponding to the eigenvalue
lambda i and if
ui belong to a single eigenspace then of
course
we only had
a difference by by sign plus or minus
one and we showed that ui transfers
one was zero
okay
and this basically means that each
nontrivial symmetry will
increment by one either k
if my eigenspace is simple
or m
if the eigenspace is not simple or it
might even happen that
both are incremented actually i
i don't have a specific example but
at least in theory nothing prevents
for
for for this situation to happen
how do you find say you have a complete
graph right how many cylinders
well then any permutation will be it
will be a symmetry so if everything is
connected then they say you're assuming
the same weights on there
so in that case
well i i i i need to think about it but
basically but my my argument is that
the more non-trivial symmetries i have
then the the bigger is my my
the bigger is this degree the bigger is
the degeneracy of my of my system
so so going back to the
optimality conditions that that i had
basically i had these two equations
one was
uh one was basically this first order
optimality with v i's
denoting the projections of the constant
vector on my eigenvectors and again i'm
assuming that i'm avoiding these
situations and the other one was the the
row sum the unit row sum condition
so i can i can split these
equations into
a system of equation for each row of f
so let's call it f i this vector of
n elements
so i have
for each i i have n
i have n such system each system
containing n plus one
variables
and n plus one equations and some
equations might be linearly dependent
okay so i i have
n plus one equation and n plus one
variables
so let's see what happens when
uh when i have unfriendly unfriendly
graphs so let's distinguish between the
between two cases so if i have a
non-hostile eigenspace
then
i know that vi is distinct from zero and
by the argument we had before i can say
that gamma i will be equal to zero so i
can eliminate this second term and i
have now n
n unknowns with
n plus 1
equations but this matrix actually has
a lot of
missing basically missing equations so
the way it will look like
i will have lambda i minus lambda 1
squared
so this is entry entry one
then until entry i minus one
i have lambda i minus lambda i minus one
and here i will have
a block of zeros
of size
m i
uh or
m i plus one m i plus one right this is
the
dimension of my of my eigen space and
then again here i will have no zero
entries
plus this additional
linearly independent equation that has
the vector v
so
the bottom line is that
my
system is rank mi deficient
okay
if i have
multiplicity if i have multiplicity of
mi plus 1 in my eigenspace
now in case of the whole star or in case
of hostile eigenspaces
i will have vi equals zero
so this means that i cannot determine
gamma i so it will remain as a degree of
freedom so i have n plus 1 degrees of
freedom and the same situation in this
matrix so this means that i'm mi plus 1
rank deficient
if i now sum all these contributions
remember i have n
such systems
so basically
this
this system of equation that tells me
what the solution has to satisfy is rank
m plus k deficient so basically this
unfriendliness degree of the graph tells
me the dimension of my solution space of
the convex realization and if the
dimension is non-zero i might be getting
some solutions that
unfortunately will fall or might fall
into uh wrong voronoi cells and give me
permutation matrices that are not
isomorphisms
okay and of course
the actual solution that i am going to
get will depend on the algorithm that
i'm i'm using and on the initialization
which is basically a question of luck
and i can here either proceed by
actually showing that for a sufficiently
large m plus k this will necessarily
happen that basically there will
necessarily be some solutions that
belong to wrong warranty cells but this
of course doesn't have a lot of
practical value because eventually i
want to solve to solve this problem so
what i will try to do instead i will try
to
show how to
uh how to make this system full rank
again
and here i will again i will show a very
a very
almost trivial
way to do it
but it leads to some thoughts of maybe
some other ways some more intelligent
ways of
of removing this deficiency
so let's
let's try to add some side information
and this is again something that is very
frequently done
in these
practical graph matching problems
one of the ways is to add seeds and
seeds are known
known correspondences between graphs so
for example if i have
one graph
and another graph i can say that this
vertex
is known to correspond to this vertex
and by the way it doesn't necessarily
need to be vertex-wise correspondence i
can say that i have some
blob corresponding to another blob or in
general i have
sets of corresponding functions
okay so i can think of these functions
as vectors so i will have a matrix each
column in this matrix will be a function
on one graph and
i will will have a corresponding matrix
d with corresponding functions on the
other graph okay
and let's say i have q such
corresponding functions i will call them
seeds
if i now transpose this matrix i can
think of it as vector valued attributes
that i'm assigning to each to each
vertex so each row in such
a matrix will be
a q dimensional vector that i'm
assigning
to
each vertex of the graph
and of course i i would i would like
these c and d to be consistent with some
preferred isomorphism i have many
isomorphisms because the graphs are
symmetric but i would like c and d to be
consistent
with with one of them okay so again you
can think of columns of c and pi star d
as corresponding functions
or rows of c and pi star d as
corresponding attributes okay
so now if i get back to the convex
relaxation i can add
a term here
that penalizes for the disagreement of
these seeds or attributes so you can see
think of it as penalty on attribute
disagreement or as a soft constrained
version of seeded graph matching so
instead of putting pc equals d as a hard
constraint i can
i can put it as a soft constraint
and this is something that is very
frequently done of course the more seeds
you put the easier it will be to solve
the problem but usually seeds
cost you something to obtain like if you
think of matching for example brain
networks these seeds come from from an
expert looking at the graphs and
manually marking points and let's say
each such point costs you a dollar you
want to minimize the number of
such known correspondences okay
well
actually now the argument will be very
simple so this looks like this looks
quite quite unnice but the the idea is
that
i can i can actually formulate
a set of constraints
that my matrix say d has to satisfy
in order for
the system to become full rank again so
so instead of going through
these details i will show you just the
argument and basically
the rest will be just technical details
so as the input we have two graphs a and
b again related by
many isomorphisms but one of them is pi
star
and i have
these attributes c and d
also
consistent with this isomorphism pi star
okay so basically i would like now to
add these
c and d to disambiguate symmetries
and we have this convex quadratic
program with
positive mu
and the global minimizer is of course by
star because if i substitute by star
here i will get zero in the objective
again i can re-parameterize it
in terms of q equals p
pi star transpose as we did before
and the global minimizer will now become
q equals i basically it is equivalent to
assuming that the two graphs have the
vertices numbered in the same way
and i would like to show that this
minimizer will be unique so again if i
get
the first order optimality condition now
this
term actually these two terms one linear
term and q another one is a constant
will be added to the uh to the logarithm
okay
and again the pseudostock system is the
constraint remains
i i can again re-parameterize this in
terms of my matrix f so what i will have
here is a linear term in f that is
multiplied from the right by this g and
this matrix g you can think of it as the
gramian matrix of the attributes
parameterized in the eigen basis of my
adjacency matrix but this matrix of
course is positive semi-definite so
adding attributes or seeds will
lead to will usually increase the rank
so the rest all all the rest is just
technical details how to make sure that
i'm adding the minimum number of
constraints to
just fill in the missing basically just
to eliminate the null space of my of my
system
okay so there will be a distinction
between
hostile and non-hostile eigenspaces
so this is an experimental
uh
evaluation on one
uh 1000 symmetric graphs with different
number of vertices and different
types and
and number of symmetries and of course
this this is a very limited experiment i
was able to
only to randomize uh
geometric graphs that come from some
from some distance function so of course
it would be interesting also to test it
on some other types of graphs but
basically what i'm plotting here on the
on the horizontal axis is the ratio
between the number of seeds satisfying
these conditions that i'm adding divided
by the number of nontrivial symmetries
so when this ratio is zero it means that
i'm solving the
the original relaxation without any
seeds and actually you can see that
the success rate here will be very small
just to visualize that in many cases you
are going to get a solution that falls
into the wrong voronoi so but when i'm
adding
the
when i'm adding the number of seeds
which is equal to the number of
symmetries
basically i'm
completely disambiguating
the system i'm making it full rank and
with
uh probability one basically
with this in this experiment i'm getting
the correct solution
okay
the optimization that you studied or the
original optimization that you showed us
at the very beginning with the
additional constraints so it's without
the additional constraints it's the fine
space
yes yes
okay so so and
and this this actually brings uh a few i
think a few interesting questions that
have some
some practical consequences so
how exactly to choose the relaxation
space how are
it looks like some constraints like this
set of constraints looks like they are
unimportant we didn't use them anywhere
and actually if you tried them in
practice i haven't seen any any uh
empirical evidence of their usefulness
now regarding the non-negativity
constraints actually actually there is
both
empirical evidence of their usefulness
and also you can show there is a recent
result by guillermo superior and marcelo
fury that
took our friendliness condition and
they showed that if you put
non-negativity constraints you actually
uh remove one
degree of freedom from the system and
you can actually show that you don't
need
this condition on uh the eigenspaces
non-orthogonal to one instead we can put
some much easier condition on the number
of num of non-zero elements in the
eigenvectors which is quite quite
surprising
but uh if we get rid of these
constraints basically it doesn't have
practical consequence in actually
solving the optimization algorithm
because you don't have overlapping
constraints anymore maybe it can lead to
some either distributed optimization
algorithm or something that can work
better in practice
also
of course all this analysis was very
naive
we are not using any kind of geometry
that actually characterizes the graphs
for example if we are assuming that
these are metric spaces the matrices are
metric they they
obey the triangle inequality they are
coming from a low-dimensional space
maybe a smooth space with bounded
curvature can we actually make use of
this to either
make stronger statements about the
applicability of the organization or
maybe do a better relaxation that will
work
at least for this kind of kinds of
graphs
for a larger family of such graphs
also one thing that i think at least
this way way of thought
uh suggests
and this this relates to what i was
saying about about random graphs so it
is very
it is very hard and probably you will
argue about any suggestion that i can
make
about
some natural distribution of graphs
but
it would probably be much easier to
to agree about
reasonable models of noise that i'm
adding to my graphs
so can i actually take
a
take adjacency matrices that are
unfriendly and i know what are what are
the eigenspaces that cause this
unfriendliness so can i actually try to
break these symmetries by introducing
some specifically designed low rank
nodes that will only affect those nasty
unfriendly eigen spaces
so by this i will break my symmetries so
the matrix will become friendly again
will the relaxation still work
because if
if this
if this is true then i can say that even
if you are giving me graphs
that are not amenable to relaxation
because of this because of this
unfriendliest property i can add some a
little bit of noise to the matrix and
with
say with probability one they will
become friendly and uh and will become
amenable to relaxation and this is a
sort of
way of thinking along what for example
dan spielman
showed for
uh for linear programming and simplex
simplex is known
so the
simplex is known to work very well in
practice
but there are some linear programs that
result in in exponential time
exponential uh complexity of simplex but
he showed that if you add random
gaussian perturbation to such problems
within this probability one simplex will
converge in polynomial time
so
can we do something similar here for
context relaxation of of graph matching
because
it looks like at least from from
empirical evidence that
despite of the theoretical complexity
these problems are not so hard so can we
make some theoretical guarantees on
modifying the problem a little bit and
making them
necessarily simple
and then another problem that is
very interesting
uh for some practical applications is
actually not finding just
one of the isomorphisms fi actually
enumerating and finding all of them if
you have for example a symmetric graph
i can be interested in finding all
automotives of this graph and
enumerating them and maybe finding some
approximate automotive up to
a certain constant so
whether can we
can we modify
these results to obtain
to obtain guarantees on an efficient
algorithm for enumerating all automotive
reasons
okay
i think i will stop here
any questions
there's a huge literature on graph
isomorphism and it seems like you didn't
touch on very much of it
and i was just curious you know i mean
for instance you know unique eigenvector
values that goes way back to the 70s or
something like that
again i i probably am not doing that
with all kinds of color refinement
algorithms which you didn't talk about
or founded degree
algorithms yes yes on and on i mean it
was just huge literature of course of
course so like you know
it would have been interesting to
compare
known literature on isomorphism with
your stuff right
of course so i'm not so i'm not arguing
that uh
well
probably this problem is studied to
death and uh
not only
results
related to this particular formulation
but there are many formulations of the
of the problem itself like for example
this quadratic distortion is something
that is used in practice for some kind
of application but there are many other
formulations like for example trying to
minimize the edit distance between
graphs and things like that and there
are there are some also some theoretical
results that are useful and of course
for many types of graphs like you're
saying with bounded degree
and uh
graphs with simple spectrum
there are there are uh
there is probably good theory but at
least what i discovered in practice and
again i'm i might be missing some uh
some amount of literature that
the constants on there so there are even
linear or almost linear uh complexity
algorithms for example for bounded
degree but the constants there are
enormously high
and the of course depending on the
degree but if the degree
in a practical graph let's say
exceeds four or five then these
algorithms will become completely
impractical
there will be like constants of millions
or maybe even more
sure
at least i've seen some some results i'm
not sure how up-to-date they are but the
constants there
look like completely unreasonable
and in fact people don't use them in
practice probably for these reasons
but i don't understand why i think
before
but yeah they require you to do group
theory but you know i don't think that
was
is that really true because you know i
mean like the color refinement
algorithms they work just very well
right i think
can you give me a references tool sorry
can you give me references to this
particular i mean there must be a
hundred references right right i think
there's all blocks okay
okay um because the obvious thing is you
wanted to make sure that your two graphs
the eigenvectors are or not or you know
or distinct i don't are all orthogonal
to the all ones but you could do that
trivially by saying well clearly some
vertex over here has to be mapped to
someone over here
and if i'm willing to pick that
and then go from there then then by then
they they're all the eigenvectors will
have that property
yes of course but if you have simple
spectrum we can just uh take one of the
bases divided by the other one and you
will get the permutation up to a sign
if you remove the sign you get the
permutation
probably interesting interesting
phenomena happen when you you don't have
simple spectrum
i mean but there's all kinds of work on
all that right and that was a classic
study problem
well
again i will be very happy to educate
myself about this
maybe so maybe somebody the applied
community can can benefit from from
these results if they're if they need to
something practical
do you have the combinatorial
characterization of friendliness
what do you mean by a community so you
have the spectral characteristics like
spectral definition can you like state a
combinatorial condition on your graph
that will imply trendlines well
at least i didn't think in this
direction because i wanted to
characterize uh the graphs in some way
that is easy to check but
uh probably you can you can you can make
some statements
uh yeah i don't have any
i don't have any any results that i can
i can show but
i'm sure you can make you can make some
statements like for example
uh this orthogonality to or
non-organized to one obviously excludes
regular graphs and
things like that okay
so i don't know what is what is the
combinatorial
characterization of a simple spectrum
for example
um
and it would probably would be
interesting
to relate these this characterization to
the properties of the laplacian
because if you relate
to the properties of the plushen then
you maybe
you will be capable of
stating something about the properties
of the
of the of the opera plus built grammy
operator if you assume that your graph
is sampled from from a minifigure
so